uh thanks to the organizers for putting
this week together
today i'll be talking about some recent
work on random ksat
and all of this is joint work with my
wonderful advisor guy
so in random ksat we sample a k c and f
with m clauses
by sampling all the literals iid and
uniformly
from n propositional variables and their
negations
this is one of the oldest studied
problems in average case computational
complexity
the interesting regime of this problem
is when the number of clauses scales
linearly with a number of variables
so it makes sense to parametrize the
problem by a clause density m over n
and with this parametrization we can
immediately ask two natural questions
first at what clause densities does a
satisfying assignment exist
and second
at what clause densities
can we find a satisfying assignment
efficiently
we call these limits opt and alg
it turns out that opt is much larger
than alg
so a third natural question is
what prevents efficient algorithms from
succeeding beyond alg and can we come up
with some explanation of why algorithms
fail beyond alg
that generalizes to explain the alg
values of other problems
throughout we work in the following
double limit
we take k to be a large constant
the clause density alpha to be a
function of k
and having fixed both parameters
um we take n to infinity
in this limit the value of opt is known
exactly it's this value here as was
confirmed by a paper of things lion's
sun
and it's about 2 to the k log2
but a lot less is known about alg
the current best algorithm that we know
is fixed by coding
which succeeds up the clause density
about 2 to the k log k over k
this is almost the whole factor of k
less than opt
so there's a very large information
computation gap
moreover
we have some heuristic structural
evidence that this gap is inherent
and no algorithm should be able to be
out
and this is because of the dramatic
phase transition
in the solution space of random k-sat
around 2 to the k log k over k
namely below this threshold the solution
space looks like one large connected
cluster
but above it it looks like exponentially
many small disconnected clusters
and in the shattered regime
local search heuristics are powerless
and that's some evidence that algorithms
should fail
we will confirm this heuristic picture
to a large extent
we show that due to shattering the class
of low-degree polynomial algorithms
can't solve this problem at clause
density is
only a constant factor above that
predicted value of alg
literary polynomials are a computation
class where all the output coordinates
are polynomials of degree atmos d in the
inputs
we think of d as being about log n hence
low degree
we can input a case that instance
into a low degree polynomial by first
encoding it as a vector of indicators
so we use a one hot encoding
where we allocate two n indicators for
the two n possible values of each
literal
and we feed this into a low degree
polynomial and get out a vector in r to
the n
which we can interpret as an assignment
by simply taking the sign
so think of positive as meaning true and
negative as meaning false
and we say that a literary polynomial
solves a random case site instance
fee
if this assignment that we get
is approximately satisfying to fee
here approximate means two things at the
same time
uh first we're allowed to be wrong in a
couple bits so a small fraction of bits
and we're allowed to fix a small
fraction of bits however we want
and second uh that resulting assignment
needs to satisfy most clauses of v
so this is some relaxed notion of solve
and note that by relaxing the notion of
solve we make any hardness result
against solving only stronger
we also require these two
[Music]
stability and normalization constraints
on the literary polynomial
um
are there any questions about this
computation model
problems that work in this model
yes um i'll show that on the next slide
so this computation class can simulate a
lot of the best algorithms for
random k-stat and for average case
problems in general
most notably they can simulate fix
so the best polytime algorithm for
random k-set is
is a literary
polynomial moreover we have there's been
an emergent
understanding
that for a lot of statistical problems
we think low-degree polynomials are as
strong as the best
uh polytime algorithms
and because of this a negative result
against literary polynomials
is quite strong evidence
that the problem is computationally
intractable
we can now state our main result
we define this constant kappa star to be
about 4.9
and our result is that
if kappa is larger than kappa star and
we have a random ksi instance
at clause density um kappa times
uh the predicted value of alg then no
lotarian polynomial can solve this
k-stat
problem with um
with a large probability that depends on
the degree
one limitation of our result is that we
can only rule out algorithms succeeding
with very large probability
but we do think that when algorithms
succeed
they do succeed with quite large
probability
still it would be nice to roll out
algorithms succeeding at a lower
probability
and we leave this as a direction for
future research
and what is the meaning of most clauses
here is this with a fraction of clauses
tending to one
um a fraction of clauses um that's
constant in n but
depend on k
so think like all but i don't know three
to the minus k fraction plus
uh did i see a question over here
this result is part of a long line of
algorithmic lower balance on random psat
so of these results there's two that i
want to highlight
first is the result of gamora against
sudan against balanced sequential local
algorithms on any k set
um this uses a very nice argument
which is quite related to our techniques
um and second is the paper by heteric
against um survey propagation guided
destination
which um you'll notice gets all the way
down to the predicted value of alg
so that's the first result um
that gets all the way down to alg
our contribution
will be the first impossibility result
against a class of algorithms
um
that gets within a constant factor of
what we think is the truth
and because this class contains fix
for the first time we have a positive
result and a negative result on the same
class of algorithms with only a constant
factor gap
we'll prove this result using the
overlap gap property
which is um one formalization of the
clustering phenomenon
so the overlap gap property holds if in
your solution space
any two solutions are either close or
far
think of closest meaning in the same
cluster and far as meeting in different
clusters
recently the overlap gap property has
emerged as a um
a general topological explanation of
hardness
and for a lot of average case problems
there's been a lot of work
much of which is by people in this room
showing that the overlapped gap property
implies various classes of algorithms
fail
next i'm going to outline the proof of
our result
to introduce the ideas we'll start with
the ensemble ogp
which is a simplification of our
technique
this method originated in this line of
papers
in the context of random ksat
the ensemble ogt will show
that lotari polynomials fail
above this intermediate clause density
which is smaller than opt but still far
larger than out
the argument goes
suppose um that a lottery polynomial
solves random ksat with quite high
probability at this class density
then we construct this interpolation
path
of correlated case instances
where the first case sign instance is
drawn um from the case distribution
and every subsequent psi instance is
drawn by resampling one literal of its
predecessor
so each of these fees is marginally
from the case side distribution
and the first and last are fully
independent
and the middle ones are some mixture of
the personal
we loss the algorithm on all the fees to
get a sequence of assignments x
um
our proof relies on the following
structure not existing
the structure consists of
two assignments each satisfying some fee
not necessarily the same one
and that's where the term ensemble comes
from
such that
the two assignments are a medium
distance from each other
and at this clause density that we
needed
this um
this overlap structure won't occur
by the following first moment argument
we can plot 1 over n log of the
expectation of the number of pairs of
satisfying assignments at each overlap
and if you look at the plot at some
point in the middle it'll go negative
and
at the overlap values where this
excitation is negative
well then that expectation is
exponentially small
so that means that with high probability
this
overlap structure won't exist
given that let's see how we um complete
the proof
so remember that if the algorithm
existed
then every x will satisfy its b with
high probability
in this cartoon i've drawn x0
and i've
drawn as a red moat the set of
assignments at medium distance for f
zero
um
i've also drawn x the last assignment
xkm
which is far away i.e outside the moat
because the corresponding fees are
independent and independent case site
instances won't have satisfying
assignments that are too close
now if we follow the sequence of x's
by the stability of literary polynomials
we only ever move by small jumps
that means we can't ever jump over the
mode
but we eventually get to the other side
so at some point we land in the mode
and when we do well then x0 and that
assignment
both satisfy some v
and by construction are a medium
distance
this contradicts the ogp
so the algorithm cannot exist
yes
but x4 satisfies the fourth formula not
the zeroth formula yes good point um
that's why um if we look at the
forbidden structure we require the
assignments to satisfy to satisfy some
fee not necessarily the same one
any other questions
so this argument gets stuck
at that intermediate clause density
because below it that first moment
argument that i showed no longer works
the graph doesn't go negative anymore
so to improve past
the intermediate clause density
we're going to use the following
enhancement
where instead of looking at a forbidden
structure of two assignments at medium
distance
we look at a forbidden structure
involving several assignments
um
as intuition for why this should help
let's look at that plot um
at a clause density just above alp
you'll notice that the plot doesn't go
negative anymore
but um
it still has a dip in the middle
and that means that if you look at
the num the overlaps at that um
at that value
remember the y-axis is a log scale
so that means that
uh the middle overlap forms an
exponentially small minority
so it exists in some sense it's rare
and that um
in that inspires the following idea
if we consider a forbidden structure
with a lot of medium overlaps
then hopefully we can boost this
unlikelihood
until we arrive at a first moment that's
actually negative
and this is what we'll do
so this technique is called the ensemble
multiogp
and it originated in this very nice
paper by alex wein
this argument will rule out
um lotarian polynomials at any clause
density above the one we claimed
and the argument uh perceives similarly
so we first
assume
we first perceive a contradiction
and the interpolation path is about the
same as before
but instead of um
resampling all the literals once
after we get to the end we go back to
the beginning and do it again
a total of k times
so now any two fees separated by at
least km are fully independent and all
the fees are still um marginally from
the case side distribution
we run the algorithm on all the fees and
get out some assignments
we're going to need the following
forbidden structure
okay so can you explain
how you've got the translations up again
um
can you really explain how you've got
the interpolation path i just didn't
understand why things came apart
sure um
so we re-sample um
the first literal from the k-state
distribution
and every cell system literally by for
every subsequent case that instance by
resampling one literal of its
predecessor
so after km steps we're fully
independent
good question
we're going to need the following
forbidden structure
um
to define this we need a notion of
multi-distance
from one assignment to a collection of
assignments
and i'm going to purposely keep this
vague for now
defining this properly will be one of
our
main innovations
so the forbidden structure consists of
k assignments each satisfying sum fee
again not necessarily the same one
um such that the if assignment
has medium multi-distance to the side of
its predecessors
and by some involved first moment
argument this structure will not exist
let's take this for granted for now
and see how we get the contradiction
so as before with high probability each
x will satisfy its corresponding fee
assuming the algorithm exists
and now i've drawn x0
and a red mode of assignments at medium
multi-distance now from the singleton
set at zero
and again xkm is far from is outside the
smoke by independence
if we follow the x's
again we only ever move by small jumps
also um
okay sorry
um
we're going to construct this forbidden
structure of ys one y at a time
so we'll always take y one to be f zero
and now we follow the x's
um
by stability of low degree polynomials
we only ever move by small jumps
so we never jump over the moat
but we eventually get to the other side
so at some point we land in the moat
what we do we call that assignment y2
note that y2 is at medium distance from
y1
and now we consider the new mode of
assignments
at medium multi-distance
from the pair y1 y2
which is x0 x4
again if you look km steps ahead
um we get an assignment that's outside
the mode by independence
so now if we follow the x's
by the same argument
um
we'll eventually land in the moat
we call that assignment y3
and so on and so forth
this procedure will construct a copy of
the structure that was forbidden on the
previous slide
and because of this contradiction
the algorithm a cannot exist
of course the key step in the previous
um proof
which i've so far glossed over
is how to define this forbidden
structure
i.e how do we pick the red moats
so that
um the forbidden structure defined by
them actually has an exponentially small
first moment
and this is really hard
the only previous problem where this has
been done
is the paper by alex wein on max
independent set and there alex uses this
ingenious construction
where um
the forbidden structure consists of
some independent sets
where the if independent set
has
a medium non-intersection
with the union of its predecessors
so this is um the notion of medium
multi-distance
in max independent set
um
unfortunately this construction is quite
tailored to mac's independent set
because in max independent set
um the first moment that we have to
control is essentially dominated
by the number of distinct edges in the
union of your independent sets
whereas in random ksat or in other
problems
the corresponding first moment
has
much more complex dependencies
and it's our priority not clear
um how to pick the right forbidden
structure for k-stat
and
finding this generalization is our main
contribution
so we identify the correct forbidden
structure for random k-stat
and by an elaborate first moment
argument
we showed that this forbidden structure
doesn't occur with high probability
um also our forbidden structure is
constructed
from essentially generic energy
considerations and we believe that our
methods can be generalized
to show similar multi-ogps for other
average case problems
um
and if you remember from before um
two-way ogps tend to show
algorithms fail at some point um below
opt but still far above alg
whereas many way ogps
um
tend to show hardness quite close to if
not at up if not at alg
so
um if we can generalize
um this multi-ogp
technique to
average these problems in general
um that could be a huge win for the
community because it would show tight
hardness quite close to out for a lot of
problems
the optimal analysis for your particular
business research um
within this um
like within this particular framework at
least yes
um
there is a question of how to um
how to shape that constant factor of
4.911
um
we believe that it's it's not possible
at least with our techniques we can
um
there's like no similar structure for
bit structure or like this particular
formula structure won't do it um the
particular like paint for bin structure
that on like two slides ago it doesn't
do it so for instance it's not possible
that this forbidden structure does do it
but first moment computation starts
your analysis of this forbidden
structure like there's some threshold
where this province structure uh starts
appearing or this forbidden structure
uh
starts becoming forbidden yeah
do your your analysis methods pin down
that threshold precisely or is it
possible that your analysis is losing a
constant factor from where this thing
starts to become
um
good question so
we showed the threshold for like 4.901
um and we showed that this analysis
can't push beyond 1.7 something and we
didn't try to optimize this constant
um
okay
in the rest of this talk i'm going to
describe how we define the forbidden
structure
to define this we need a notion of
overlap profile
so for l assignments
their overlap profile summarizes all the
ways that these assignments can agree or
disagree
formally it's a vector of length
2 to the r minus 1
indexed by the um
unordered partitions of size 2
of the set 1 through l
where pi st
is
the fraction of coordinates
where all the y's indexed by s agree and
all the y is indexed by t agree
um note that unlike for independent set
where the forbidden structure only
needed to care about the
non-intersection of one set with the
union of its predecessors
here we actually need to know all the
ways that these assignments agree and
disagree
and we can think of this pi as a
probability distribution because pi st
is the probability that if you pick a
random coordinate then you get the
agreement pattern st
and we can take the entropy of this
probability distribution we define this
as the overlap entropy
in some sense this measures the
diversity of the set of
assignments y1 through yl
and now we can define the forbidden
structure as follows
we pick a constant beta star to be about
3.5
and our forbidden structure
is um the first half of the definition
is as before
and now we can fill in the medium
multi-distance condition
we define the multi-distance of y i to
the set of its predecessors
as the overlap entropy of y 1 through y
i
minus the overlapping entropy of y 1
through y i minus 1.
so this
[Music]
is the additional diversity contributed
by the coordinate
by the assignment y i
you can also think of this as an over as
a conditional entropy
and the median multi-distance condition
is that this multi-distance
is about beta star log k over k
so this defines the forbidden structure
at the heart of our um multi-ogp
and our paper um
uses a first moment analysis to show
that um
this doesn't occur with high probability
in summary we generalized the ensemble
multi-ogp
which was previously tailored to max
independent set
to random case set
and we believe that um
our methodology can be adapted to other
average case problems
for random k-stat we show that literary
polynomials don't solve it
at a clause density that's a constant
factor
above the predicted value of alg
and i guess the takeaway is that many
way ogps
can show algorithmic hardness at or just
beyond alg
and i'm confident that this method
can be used to attack many other
problems as well
and with that
i suppose i segway into mark's talk
which talks about um
tight algorithmic hardness for another
problem using an even more evolved
multi-way otp thanks for your attention
i'm sorry i'm still missing something
really jason so
the
you have this chain of assignments
and the ith one is allowed to the only
condition is that it satisfies one of
the many
formulas
so i still don't understand
why it can't fall into the most of the
first formula
right or the mo of the uh
well the mode around the first
yeah i'm sorry i mean what isn't the
moving as we
change we're canted
that's a really good question so i guess
i'm not sure it's a good question
like polynomially many clauses or
polynomially many case sentences
and um
like really this like you can think of
this expectation as a sum over like
if you like case on which case-size
instances are being satisfied
um and like you know that gets you a
poly factor in front
but all these failure probabilities are
exponentially small
so like the fact that you have this
ensemble only contributes um
like a poly factor which gets swallowed
by the end stone
and it turns out that this um
like the the probability of the failure
of this the probability of the forbidden
structure occurring
ends up being maximized when all the two
seconds are the same because when
they're different you only have you only
get additional randomness which makes
sense worse
basically
sort of like super sort of three phase
videos
just that the forbidden structure is
something more complicated it's not
considering just a single formula it's
saying you can't have y one and y two
and satisfy any formulas i don't care
among the whole collection that
overlapped by this amount
and then generalized to many such
solutions
okay
and then and then by the reasons you
said the first moment calculation sort
of doesn't care if you allow them to be
solutions to anything within this
question
so you're saying even if i define the
new
csp which is the
what you just said you
satisfying me and satisfying any one of
these in the chain
that
thing
still has this overlap gut property in
its solutions exactly
okay i didn't catch that thanks
a little bit of intuition for why your
choice of forbidden instructor ended up
being the
correct one
i guess it looked
maybe complicated
but um
well if you look at like the expectation
or forbidden structure
um
you got a
you know a combinatorial term
corresponding to the number of ways um
yeah like number of potential energies
of the forbidden structure and you've
got a probability term
of the you know the probability that
some coffee satisfies
um
[Music]
and
like
these two
um
bs2 terms have some trade-offs
and um by some analysis we can manage
the trade-off of these and show that
like
when you're
when your overlap entropy is just this
much that's when the trade-off is the
worst
so this is informed about three-phase
analysis and you just
the expectation
the previous because
it does not work
so this choice of this entropy
right is informed by the previous
analysis of the previous forbidden
structure that wouldn't give you the
result that you want that's right
can i uh
make a comment
okay
uh i don't know if you hear me uh yeah i
i just wanted to say that
i think
this work and to some extent previous
work
highlight some interesting thing
that the hardness if we believe the
hardness is indeed occurs at 2 to the k
over k
you can't really read this hardness from
from the associated gibbs distribution
because if you look at the overlap
distribution of of randomly chosen
uh assignments uh the overlap uh
is is going to be trivial so it's
i guess what you you would call it
replica symmetric regime
uh which is which is different from
p-spin models where the overlap distribu
overlap distribution
is informative of the hardness but in
this case i guess the problem is heart
even though the gibbs distribution is is
trivialized not the
gibbs distribution but the overlap
associated with gibbs distribution so i
guess the lesson at least for me is is
that you can't really read the hardness
of the problem from the associated gibbs
distribution
interesting
well there's i think there's a partial
answer to this uh which is that if you
look at the free energy this expected
number of things that are overlapping
there's that did there so if you think
about sort of like an average case
version of ogp then
at least intuitively there's
exponentially fewer there like like
price explained and that's getting
amplified by this construction
um
also you can see it
from the gibbs distribution if you will
get point to set collaborations
look at distributions of
pairs i mean it's bishop basis too
doesn't have uh two deltas but it has a
if you look at the large division
functions it has
a maximum right what's called the parisi
transpotential
in physics you pick one random solution
and then you look at the distribution of
of solutions at distance d from that
kind of solution
that is the secondary maximum that
appears
that is
in case after this thing and that has
been all the longer pieces came out
i i i couldn't catch half of that so
i'll leave it
when i'm back
what's up
[Music]